veamos si podemos calcular el resultado
de sumar 5 sextos más un cuarto y para
ayudarnos tengo una representación
visual de 5 sextos y una representación
visual de un cuarto fíjense que tengo
este entero completo dividido en 1 2 3 4
5 6 secciones y el sombreado 5 lo que
representa 5 sextos y luego aquí abajo
tengo otro entero y tengo identificada
una de las cuatro secciones iguales lo
que representa un cuarto y quiero
sumarlas los ánimos que pausa en el
vídeo y que intenten resolverlo por
ustedes mismos cuando sumamos fracciones
nos gusta pensar en fracciones que
tengan el mismo denominador y estas
fracciones evidentemente no tienen el
mismo denominador y para reescribir las
con un denominador común tenemos que
encontrar un múltiplo común para 64 y
queremos obtener el mínimo común
múltiplo para 64
y lo que hacemos es tomar el mayor de
los números que en este caso es el 6 y
pensar en sus múltiplos así que el
primero es el mismo 6 que claramente es
divisible entre 6 pero no es exactamente
divisible entre 4 entonces lo
multiplicamos por 2 y obtenemos 12 y
vemos que 12 es divisible entre 6 y
entre 4 12 es un buen denominador común
es el mínimo común múltiplo para el 6 y
el 4 ahora podemos escribir estas
fracciones como algo sobre 12 entonces
tengo algo sobre 12 más algo sobre 12 es
igual hay muchas maneras de resolver
esto pero quiero que lo visualicemos en
estos dibujos si paso de seis secciones
iguales a doce secciones iguales que es
lo que estoy haciendo estoy pasando del
denominador 6 al denominador 12
esencialmente estoy multiplicando el
número de secciones que tengo por 2
o estoy dividiendo las secciones que
tengo aquí entre 2
déjenme hacerlo
y lo voy a hacer con cuidado
lo estoy dividiendo a ojo tal vez no sea
tan exacto
muy bien
muy bien fíjense que tenía seis
secciones pero duplique el número de
secciones pase de seis secciones a doce
al dividir cada sección original en dos
así que ahora tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 secciones cuántas de esas
secciones están sombreadas ahora si
tengo 5 secciones sombreadas de las 6 es
lo mismo que tener 10 de 12 así que
ahora tengo 10 12 a 25 sextos es lo
mismo que 10 doceavos otra manera de ver
esto es la siguiente al pasar de 6 a 12
tenemos que multiplicar por 2 así que
debemos hacer lo mismo con el numerador
5 por 2 es igual a 10
afortunadamente pueden ver cómo estas
dos fracciones son equivalentes porque
no cambien las secciones sombreadas lo
único que hice fue pasar de 6 secciones
a 12 multiplique el total de secciones
por 2 para obtener 12
y ahora en lugar de tener 5 sextos tengo
10 doceavos de secciones sombreadas
vamos a hacer lo mismo con un cuarto
como ven aquí tengo un cuarto sombreado
pero debemos escribirlo como algo sobre
12 para hacer esto debemos tener 3
secciones por cada sección original
vamos a convertir cada sección en tres
secciones
ahora tenemos uno
2 y 3
aquí tenemos 1 2 y 3
tengo 1 2 y 3
y tengo uno
2 y 3
vieron todo lo que hice fue convertir
cada sección en tres ahora tengo doce
secciones iguales y esencialmente lo que
hice fue multiplicar cada sección por
tres ahora qué fracción está sombreada
bueno ahora un cuarto que estaba
asombrado corresponde a tres de las doce
secciones iguales ahora es tres de las
doce secciones iguales entonces cuál es
el resultado tengo 10 12 a 2 + 3 12 a
vos esto es igual a 13 12 a vos y lo
podemos visualizar acá también aquí
arriba tengo 10 12avo sombreados cada
uno de estos cuadros son 12 a 2 y lo voy
a escribir aquí esto corresponde a un
doceavo esto es un doceavo esto también
es un 12 ago entonces tengo 10 doceavo
sombreados luego 11 12 a vos 12 12 a vos
y finalmente 13 12 a vos
esta es otra forma de resolverlo